[Music]
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields melbourne
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists from our beds and
couches to our cars and desks human
beings are more sedentary than ever
after decades of sitting in chairs and
staring at screens we've lost access to
basic human movement the average person
can't touch their toes
sit in a deep squat or perform a single
pull-up of course there's a direct
correlation between our physical health
and our psychological well-being if we
want to change the quality of our lives
we must first change
the way we move how do we do that
well that's what we're talking about
today here on the public podcast we're
speaking about
functional movement with aaron alexander
he's the author of this new book the
align method we're gonna be talking
about that and then this thursday on the
minimalist private podcast aaron ryan
and i we're going to discuss how you can
align your mind body and movements we're
also going to talk about improving your
posture flexibility and so much more you
can check that out at patreon.com
the minimalist your support keeps our
podcast 100
advertisement free because
advertisements suck
erin thanks so much for being here today
thanks for doing this man who writes
that that was excellent i need to hire
you for my next book
well you know josh has been doing it for
uh 30 or 40 years basically
yeah
he's got the hang of it that's beautiful
thank you well this is a listener driven
show and so we're going to dive right
into the questions this is really how
we're going to talk about alignment
about movement about functionality our
first question today is from facebook
gerald has a question for us what simple
exercises can we do every day to keep
our bodies moving correctly
well so
in the what do you call it the the
maximal episode the maximal episode we
went through some of this stuff the one
thing that i would recommend that would
be very simple and very accessible uh
would just be to introduce a pull-up bar
into your home
so the reason that that is relevant a
big part of what the align method
represents is changing
the way that we
perceive fitness to not be a thing that
we do but who we are
so all day you know every moment
throughout the day you have a choice of
the way that you breathe the way that
you use your eye muscles the way that
you communicate and the way that you
change the shape of your home so we
become the shape of our home and so an
example to start to change that shape to
change our own physical shape would be
throw a pull-up bar in between like some
doorway you walk through with regularity
uh each day hang from that pull-up bar
a total of 90 seconds would be the
recommendation in the book oh wow and
totally that could be ten seconds at a
time ten seconds nine times fifteen six
you know whatever you know how are you
i'm glad i got the match right that was
i was kind of guessing you know i
checked out right that was correct he'll
check young he's the human advocate
and so the reason that that is relevant
is as we are sitting you know phones in
hand sitting in desks you know in
forward head posture and all four
shoulders and all those things as we
discussed in the other conversation it's
not
bad it's not a moralistic judgment of
like you're doing a bad job you're a
naughty postural person um it just has
effect and it has outcome you know and
what that effect does for one thing is
it's going to impede your ability to get
a full breath of air it's going to
impede your ability to communicate and
perhaps express that you feel confident
in conversation uh it's probably going
to reduce the level of attraction from
the opposite sex
because opposite sex is looking for
someone that feels stable secure safe
feels like at home in their bodies yeah
they feel at home that it makes me feel
at home we can kind of have this like
home thing and so a simple thing of just
getting your arms up overhead hanging it
literally changes the structure of the
shoulder girdle there's specific
anatomical parts that i'm not going to
describe because it doesn't feel
appropriate um and
from that position
when you come down off of that you've
opened up the space around the lungs
you've opened up the ribs you've the
shoulders can then sit back you've
elongated the spine and it's easier for
your body to just be able to rest into
uh you know a stacked well-oriented
position you know when i first heard you
bring a pull-up bar in your book i was
going towards you encouraging people
every time they walked through the
doorway to do a pull-up or like to do an
arm hang yeah and when you when you
talked about just hanging from it i'm
like that's the simplest advice that you
could possibly give someone who's
looking to change their body a little
bit just hang yep yeah yeah and that's
the thing is you don't need to i think
so much of our culture is about this
gets into minimalism is about adding
yeah it's like we don't need to add
anything new we can just do better with
what we have you know so start to value
the possessions that you have start to
value your your physical biological
possession yes you know and start to
really take interest of like okay i
don't need to add a bunch of new
workouts and new exercise like i think i
have access to most of the things i need
to be healthy yeah yes like what a
bummer of a world that we'd live in that
you need to go out for this stuff yeah
in order for your cells to function
like most of it's there yeah you know a
simple example of that is just you know
starting to change the shape of your
environment just enough that you can
take your body through a full range of
motion yeah now your book is so good
about like there are some i don't know
some things that you recommend to do as
far as stretching and exercises but
that's not what your book is about your
book is really about observation
and i think that that's something that
we overlook because we're looking for
the perfect prescription we're looking
for the perfect way to do things we
don't really think about or observe kind
of where our bodies are at and uh yeah
that's your book does such a good job of
helping us just observe where we're at
yeah and that's kind of the place to
start yeah yeah absolutely yeah i mean
our postural patterns affect the way
that we think and the way that we feel
you know and one of the
the studies that i reference in in the
book is one from san francisco state
university and it was about postural
feedback which is a term of the way that
we move affecting our our state we think
what we feel psychological state and
what they found in that study uh was
groups of students that would be in a
hunched over position which is kind of
like the standard archetypal sitting in
a chair at work you know forward head
posture roll four shoulders all the
things
it was easier for groups in that
position to be able to access more like
challenging memories like melancholy
memories times that i felt kind of like
down my cat died i got dumped whatever
it is like oh you put yourself in that
position it's easier for you to kind of
open up that rolodex of when times were
hard yes when you put yourself into an
upright position you know and shoulders
back and you open up your vital organs
and you're like i'm open to the world
it's literally changes the way that a a
person acquires memories while they go
in and kind of open up their internal
filing cabinet yeah you know and so as
we're communicating to each other like
that's the
albert morabian is a professor from
harvard from the 60s he came up with a
thing called the the 55 38 7 principle
and what that is is 55 of our body
language or 55 of our communication
comes from body language yeah 38 is the
tone of our voice you know and then
there's the last seven percent which is
the actual words that we're saying wow
so if there's incongruence between what
i say with my physical postural patterns
facial expressions and the tone
of how i say the words yes there's
incongruence there with 93 consistency
you will trust the tone and the body
language over the words like if i look
at ryland i love you right and it's like
well there's that's so awful what is
going on right now josh you look great
today
yeah it's like i've seen exacerbated or
you seem annoyed
you're trusting that over the actual
words absolutely in fact that's how you
communicate sarcasm quite often right is
you present an intentional incongruity
between
one's physical being and the words and
the tonality of what's being said now
aaron during the maximal episode you
touched on we were talking about sort of
doing some things that align us better
and one of the things you said is oh
we're all standing here we're actually
standing on grounding mats we have clint
ober coming on the podcast in a few
weeks to talk about grounding but
we're standing as opposed to sitting it
doesn't mean that sitting is bad or evil
i assume you have some furniture in your
house somewhere
oh wow
hypocrite
i mean i don't sit on it
guys it just looks nice
and so
we we're standing right now but then you
said something that was fascinating to
me said i prefer that we were on the
floor
now i'm not sure what you meant by that
exactly let's hope maybe you could
expand on
why
being on the floor is a more natural
way of being than standing here for two
hours straight yeah yeah so there's uh
james levine dr james living from the
mayo clinic yes he came up with the very
popular slogan sitting as the new
smoking right
which is not really the entire story
like it's not
i would say it's it's it's false um but
it's not correct
like it's there's nuance to most
headlines yes you know like that one
that gets shared around
and
the nuance there is that it's not
sitting it's the way that we sit you
know in the previous episode we we
mentioned um some research from
university of southern california where
researchers went out and studied hatsa
tribes people in northern tanzania and
what they found is that people in uh
these tribes were getting
we're in resting positions about the
same as industrialized populations about
10 hours a day about 10 hours a day so
9.82 hours per day you know and as
they're and what they're doing is
they're resting is they're just they're
not resting inside of a box with
air-conditioned air you know and
artificial lights and hunched over in a
chair staring into a screen and you know
all the other factors that are happening
within that yeah they are squatting
every now and again they're kneeling
every now and again they're floor
sitting throughout the day you know and
then they're getting up with some level
of regularity and taking a walk they're
probably going to reach their arms up
overhead every now and again they're
probably going to relax their visual
muscles and look out into the distance
then they're going to bring their visual
muscles back in and focus on what
they're focusing on that exercise or
expansion and contraction of their
musculoskeletal system and their you
know their visual system and the way
they breathe just the way that they like
inhabit their bodies
that's health
it's not complicated you don't need a
machine you don't need a gizmo you don't
need to pay someone thousands of dollars
to like find health like we have access
to it and you don't need a technique
either and that's what's so fascinating
is i think with your book you're really
going back to the natural
movement when i think about my daughter
who's eight years old and when she was
growing up pre-kindergarten
all of her natural movements i was a bit
envious of yeah
i would i would attempt to mimic her to
the best of my ability and it would i
would often fall over and not be able to
do the same things that she was able to
do and
uh i think part of me if i will let my
ego get in the way then it would just
prevent me from doing any of those
movements whatsoever
but she moved so gracefully and
naturally
and
i have lost that capability over the
last 40 years and you moved yourself
into um an inability to access those
positions
therefore
you can probably
move yourself back into it
you know it's just it needs to become a
a routinized part of our our life where
it's not something that's like oh this
i'm doing this workout i got this new
workout thing yeah you know and i do
that and i drive across town and i do my
workout thing for 45 minutes and open up
my hips and massas and you know
re-engage my post my posterior chain you
know and then i go back into the mold
that formed me into that predicament in
the first place sure it doesn't make
sense yeah
you know and so we can start to come in
and do these subtle adjustments to our
home to our office the way that we
travel you know and the way that we use
these these basic systems that we use to
perceive the world like our eyes and our
breath and all that
and if we can start to come into like
the container that we exist in being
like our home for example then those
changes that we get with that fancy
rehabilitatory workout thing can
actually stick
but there needs to be congruence with
the way that i live and the things that
i do
you know and that's that's the big
that's the big disconnect and that's the
reason that people
pay a bunch of money do a thing back
pain is going for a little bit you know
or they feel amazing for two days or 36
hours
and then they kind of
come back
you know where they go to peru and they
drink ayahuasca
you know and they see god and snakes and
they're like oh my god like you know i
think i'm the chosen one you know you
have this moment you know of of
revelation
and then you know you go back to being a
jerk in in 10 days yeah well i got a
marketing meeting
i guess i i have to default to this yeah
and i think quite often especially with
movement and posture and flexibility we
default to what is not simple but what
is easy it is the easiest for me to sit
on this couch over here or to sit in an
office chair and get in that position
that allows me to do the work on my
glowing screen
it probably is actually the best posture
for me to do these little stupid
movements shape of the couch yeah
they're not natural movements at all um
in the sense that like
most of humanity we were not doing this
if you're watching the video version of
this on youtube i'm just basically like
staring at a screen typing yeah but as a
writer that's what i would often do for
five six seven hours a day and i've
built in a few things to get up every 25
minutes or so and do different stretches
and so forth but i still tend to default
to that
oh i'm gonna sit here in this chair
because it's the easiest thing for you
you would see an animal do that if they
were sick
expand on that so if you'd go to a you
know a zoo and there was say some
primate you know whatever the bon bon or
whatever the girl's name would be at the
zoo
and they were you know had a stomach
thing or they felt depressed they lost
bonbon lost his girlfriend
you know they might suddenly become more
despondent and you know they wouldn't
have a screen in front of them or be
holding a cell phone but they might kind
of be just sitting hunched over in this
thing and we say like what's wrong with
bonbon
you're like oh okay they're sick bon
bons
sick or sad
so that's become normalized
in western culture
and then you know we shared previously
that's the number one leading cause of
disability worldwide is depression
you know and then the gradual increase
in usage of anti-anxiety medications
anti-depressants and self-harm and
obesity
there's a lot of amazing things
happening in the world
you know it's very easy to look at
things from like a glass half empty kind
of perspective and fire and brimstone
and everything sucks and you know we're
failing and then we wrap ourselves up in
this like other double bind of like
you know we're doing it wrong yeah it's
like
we're also we're also really amazing
and we're really compassionate beings
and we love to dance and we can make art
and
you know it's like like life is a
miracle mm-hmm
so so we can also focus energy on how
freaking amazing things are
you know blow on that ember a little bit
and then see where that takes us yeah
because if we're coming from a place of
oh i'm a naughty boy i sit wrong oh i
work too much
it's all this doesn't happen it's not
motivating right
so so let's say
let's take someone like aaron who is
if you're writing or you're working at a
computer or a glowing screen what are
you doing uh that is different from
maybe your average human being how are
you moving when are you moving when are
you taking breaks all of these things
what is more natural than the way that
we're doing it right now
i would i would just take a a card from
like we we talked about you know any
pre-kindergarten person or any
lots of tribesmen or person living a
more ancestral lifestyle they're going
to be spending when they're in their
resting position which essentially is
checking your emails it's like a resting
position
assume some of the positions that might
be replicated in nature but make it a
vibe like make it comfortable make it
cool make it you know bohemian moroccan
japanese feng shui
like someone comes into your home
they're like
this is cool yeah
like i feel creative in this room
you know and then like oh cool and you
know let's like let's watch a movie or
let's make some tea or let's make some
art or whatever and
when we or make some dinner and when we
sit down we have floor cushions and
maybe i have like a low coffee table you
know and now we're going in this you
know all the way up and down off the
ground and i already this is like this
almost reminds me of being a kid
what was i like when i was a kid
i was kind of awesome
right
like as a kid you're curious you're
exploratory you know you're more playful
you're more imaginative
what makes a successful businessman
like what is elon musk you know like
it's it's or steve jobs you know i don't
know that this relates to them from a
movement perspective but from a you know
a psychological perspective it's their
capacity to explore and push boundaries
and think differently and move
differently
this is the move different part and it
ties into the way that we perceive the
world
you know so you go to a restaurant go to
a you know moroccan restaurant or
ethiopian restaurant you know or
japanese restaurant that's like
traditional and you know you're down on
the ground yes it makes you feel away
right you're like we're doing something
different here this is kind of it's like
an adventure at first though it's it's
uncomfortable in two ways one is it can
be physically uncomfortable if you're
not used to that right if i just go sit
on the floor right now i'm going to
experience some discomfort relatively
quickly compared to like my some of my
favorite japanese minimalists who own
virtually no furniture they just sit on
cushions at home
and it's gonna also feel comfortable
socially or uncomfortable socially right
like oh i'm not i'm just simply not used
to this i don't even know how to
acclimate to
this environment it's really simple so
in fact you know what uh danny we could
do this now if you want we can sort of
we have the carpet here we we've cleared
out our coffee table
maybe you could you could walk us
through yeah very simply yeah absolutely
what sitting on the floor might be like
and also while you're here getting up on
your own and i'll i'll narrate it with
ryan here okay so uh dan if you want to
move the camera over here we'll get
alabama out of the way so i can kind of
talk us through the general thing like
the takeaway message if you just do this
it's like you know worth your time of
listening to this whole entire episode
just implement this one piece when
you're sitting on a chair or on the
ground make sure that your hips are up
above the height of your knees your hips
are above your knees that's it okay
things are simple
you know like live our lives more
principally based okay that is a
principle that will overlay almost
anything that you do you know so when
you're sitting down at a desk when
you're sitting down on the ground if
your hips are up above the height of
your knees what that does is it sets up
your
pelvis and your spine to be in a
mechanically
stable strong position
when you hunch yourself over in that
kind of like sad puppy dog position yeah
they're about to get like swat with a
newspaper or something not that i would
recommend that or advocates what about a
newspaper but if they feel like they did
something wrong they go oh
yeah that position
right so just the simple act of making
sure that whatever you're sitting on the
ground
get cushions for some people the cushion
might be two feet tall
that's fine
your hips need to be above the height of
your knees from there it will be
comfortable and then you could even have
a person like push down on your
shoulders and if you can have someone
push down your shoulders your hips above
behind your knees you'll feel that
weight evenly be distributed through
your spine down into your pelvis
and you're stable and supported you can
sit there all day wow why don't you show
us here on the carpet here we'll have
you right over here we're roughly where
alabama was
so the thing that we would need is a
cushion
okay do we have a pillow or a no we're
minimalist
oh that's our lighting no you don't want
to sit on a light okay
okay
yeah okay
he's now squatting on the ground you got
to watch the youtube version of this
yeah
did you see how easily he just like sat
down sat down
crisscross applesauce with no assistance
except his legs and feet and yeah what
are you a three-year-old
so from here
i would need my hips to be up
about like that okay so he would he's
mimicking what it would be like to sit
on a big cushion therefore your hips are
above your knees i'm kind of flexible
yes
like a
cushion or three inch cushion leaf great
so he would need like a three or four
inch cushion
they might be like you know a foot off
of the ground okay okay but so by going
through when you have and then another
thing people can do is they can reach
their butt cheeks back
back back back back back and then sit
back from that position so now i'm
hinging my hips back and from here i can
load a bunch of weight from my shoulders
if it's very strong and stable
okay so that's what you'll see a baby
naturally be in this position all day so
they'll go into
if i sit here for a while it's a night
night position
for a while then maybe they're going
kneeling for a little bit
toe sit for a little bit and then maybe
they put their baby laptop on the ground
they open up their side body a little
bit
interesting yeah the yoga class that you
would pay to go to so for those of you
right
right you're just gonna mimic a child
if you're just listening to the audio
podcast you probably didn't catch a lot
of what what aaron was doing now i would
encourage you to go back and check out
the the youtube version of that yeah but
he was mimicking essentially what if you
gave a child a laptop
how they would work while they're on the
floor in fact what's so fascinating
about this i saw this my my greatest
regret as a parent is ever giving ella a
tablet even though she does relatively
well with the tablet yeah um but she
does many of the things that you were
just showing us right there when she is
watching the tablet if we give her half
hour an hour of screen time she's not
stationary in one position
she's squatting she's laying on her side
she's laying on her back she's doing all
these different sort of movements moving
into all of these positions constantly
yeah it's the opposite of what we do is
hey i'm gonna sit in this chair
for the next four hours until my lunch
break yep with bad posture yeah and then
at lunch no bad posture
oh yeah it's not a moralistic thing yeah
this is just a posture thank you that
will guide the body into um lacking
access to power yeah
potentially increasing the likelihood of
disc herniation or some type of spinal
disease
um increasing likelihood of developing
osteoarthritis in the hips and the knees
which is over a 30 billion dollar
industry in the united states having hip
replacements knee replacements and um
and osteoarthritis yeah so all of that
all of those ailments
are absolutely 1 000 preventable
it's just choosing to engage with those
parts of our body it is not something
that you need to do it is a choice that
you have the opportunity to elect to do
yeah such an important distinction yeah
and so it's not about the well i need to
go to yoga three times a week and that's
gonna fix my problem you're not talking
about fixing
anything
in a way you're actually talking about
regressing
because we've progressed our way out of
movement right we we are trying to be
the brain in a vat that just sits here
and you know
contemplates or whatever
what's the the saying about like man's
deepest fears like being uh sitting
still alone in an empty room
but but of course like if you sit still
long enough in an empty room you're
actually not moving you're not being a
human being
and so we're afraid of the the moving
mind but in a way we're afraid of our
moving selves but stillness also is
there's an art and science to stillness
yes
right so sitting still you know that is
like the the root of all of man's
problems is the inability to sit alone
with themselves in a room and if you can
tap into that place and be comfortable
in your body
just with yourself
you don't need to have stimuli in order
to be okay you're like an addict
i'm an addict you're probably an addict
like we're all like yeah we're all right
you're in the like the modern stew
you're probably an addict yes like let's
just be honest yeah you know let's have
compassion for each other yeah amen
that's why i love how you like took away
the morality of posture because that's
what we want to do we want to moralize
everything yeah and instead um yeah it's
it's being with each other rather than
being like this is good this is bad yeah
yeah and that's right that's the first
step and that's like you know making
progress in a conversation with somebody
or maybe having a dispute with somebody
or relationship thing or whatever it's
creating a safe container to be
wildly vulnerable and honest
100 yeah so we don't need to lead with
like oh like i'm mr aligned guy i'm
looking straight
you know upright always sitting on the
ground like
that's not it no i've got issues i've
got problems
you know and i i choose to create these
basic anchors throughout my day and i
choose to observe my environment and i
sit back and say like how
am i gonna form in this room
you know so if i'm
changing my space and i'm decluttering
or i'm going more of a minimalist or
proud approach
what does that do to my my cells what
does that do to my musculoskeletal
system my structure well one it opens up
space for me to move yes
right so if i'm in a cluttered space i
actually got a home from a gal who
recently passed away um but she was a uh
hoarder
and so coming into her place she's known
as like a like a mole hoarder and so she
had it was like pathways yes
stages
are amazing
pathways big open space and the way that
you go through the like newspapers
stacked up like you know it was it was
really like
boxes stacked inside the bathtub
really impressive and so
in that home
how is that person able to move and
express
their bodies they're going to kind of
shuffle around here here here you open
up that space suddenly it opens up the
ability to like i can lay down on the
ground
now suddenly my arms are going into this
range i didn't do anything
i was essentially moved by the container
that i existed in it's like it's like a
goldfish growing to the size of the
container
yeah you know so it's like okay
interesting make some space maybe i'll
get a comfy rug that's inviting for
people to come down to the ground yeah
maybe i'll put some floor cushions maybe
over there i have a yoga mat or i have a
pull-up bar i've got some myofascial
release balls i've got a foam roller
just stuff it doesn't need to be weird
it doesn't need to be crazy
just little subtle things that remind
you that you're this this this physical
being yeah and your body matters and
your health matters
yeah the the space we often feel so
compelled to fill
the space with things
as opposed to enjoying the vastness of
the space
it's fascinating ryan and i lived in
montana for
uh four or five years and no one ever
goes to like montana says man we really
need to fill all this open space with
something
you know but like in our homes it's like
well i've got spare room of course i
need to fill this with things hey what
do you think i should put in here talk
about moralizing and then all of a
sudden it's like what should i do here
what shouldn't i do as opposed to like
wow
look at all this open space yeah what
opportunities are here for me to move
yeah yeah i don't have to fill it with
things i could fill it with movement
yeah we have a lot of should on us
and i'm like over it i'm like good on
the should mm-hmm good on the ship
tweet that podcast sean
ryan let's move on to the lightning
round tell me what time it is oh you
know what time it is it's time for the
lightning round where we answer your
text messages you can text your
questions your comments your smart
remarks to 937-202-4654
now aaron during the lightning round
this is where we and our guests we try
to answer questions with a short
shareable less than 140 character
response we call them minimal maxims but
don't worry we just ramble on a bit and
eventually podcast sean tweezes out
something pithy and beautiful so people
can copy and share our pithy answers
it's right there from the show notes you
can share it on social media if you'd
like you can find all of our minimal
maxims in one place minimalmaxims.com
we have a question here from satya for
people who work long hours at their
desks what do we need to consider when
it comes to the ergonomics of our
workplace you know so we've been
touching on this already aaron but
ergonomics are this is often the
consumerist way of trying to
fix
my
problem that i've created by these
unnatural
working environments right so it's like
yeah well you know what the problem is i
need a better keyboard right i need the
lumbar support on my chair
i need this thing to swivel i need the
desk that tilts at this particular angle
and any of these things might actually
help to some
degree but it could also be that they're
exacerbating the problem right yeah yeah
yeah within that it's like
simple is typically better
and and the simple principles from an
ergonomic perspective of how to make
your office environment better or more
effective more mechanically efficient is
like i had mentioned just make sure that
whatever seat you're on make sure you're
able to get your hips up above the
height of your knees
so that's like an easy simple bass line
hips up by the height of the knees check
you put a little ball on your femur on
your thigh if it rolls down you're
already in an advantageous position okay
you know and then from there making sure
that you know extending the idea of what
is
range of motion what is fitness into our
visual muscles and saying okay what am i
looking at am i just looking at this
screen for eight hours at a time
or whatever amount of hours at a time
change the position of the screen so
it's nearby a window
so if you're working a laptop just like
you know reorient your desk so that you
have the window actually open the window
up all the way so you're not blocking
out a certain spectrum of light through
you know multi-planed uh uh
what however it's double glass double
pane yeah exactly double pane glasses
glass windows
actually opening the window getting
fresh air in being able to look out into
the woods or wherever you're looking at
relaxing your visual muscles causes your
autonomic nervous system to calm down
so when we can
relax our visual muscles just for a
moment you know get maybe every five
minutes ten whatever you want it's not a
rule
like every person's different we're
always looking for like the perfect
contained structured things like
if you feel a little stressed take a
moment and unwind
whatever that is for you yes whatever a
moment is whatever unwinding is right
and and and a physiological structural
expression of unwinding is relaxing your
eye muscles
taking in the the the panoramic view
another part of that unwinding because
your visual muscles are tied into your
nervous system would be tapping into
your breathing muscles
so if you are
in that decompressive moment you can
stack another variable being breath and
you can have a
even audible exhalation if you're
feeling stressed out you've got a
meeting thing and whatever it may be
you're just feeling yourself build up
cortisol norepinephrine
relax the eyes
um
yeah cool yeah check in
you can do that any time yeah right
as long as you have the right desk chair
right exactly and the right keyboard
yeah no i love in your book how you and
i don't think we have time to unpack it
right now but you talk about the five
different gears when it comes to breath
right and uh
that alone uh was mind-blowing not to
mention the other stuff you have in
there i know you did a podcast episode
on it as well maybe we could find that
and put a link to it in the show notes
uh podcast sean but yeah um the breath
is such a powerful thing man like just
starting with that is and it's it's
knowing once again there's no right
wrong there's this type of breathing
will cause you to feel this type of way
when we visit this type of results
so understanding how to use your breath
in more of like a
like like a hyper
ventilatory type way or
yeah like what does that replicate right
that replicates extreme exercise you
know or some type of like wow like in
the book we call it the fifth gear which
i you know i borrowed from a friend
called brian mckenzie um and i've done a
podcast with brian as well we like get
into all of that and going through the
gear systems of how we breathe so
having access to be able to just turn
yourself into that high level you know
your body's going to start to release
things like norepinephrine and kind of
put yourself in a very ready to go ready
to fight flight type state
by going through that
yeah
the opposite side is saying wow when i'm
just sitting here having a hoagie
checking my instagram notifications i
caught people can audibly hear me mouth
breathe
oh my god
yeah right oh man now i want a hoagie
so in that situation now we're okay
we're in first gear so now how can we
start to extend our access to first and
second gear yeah that more exp there's
more moments of exposure in life it
takes more to get me out of those gears
yeah where i'm suddenly tony robbins i'm
up on stage with 50 000 people or
whatever
and um
calm yeah thank you guys for coming out
yeah let's go heck yeah first gear yeah
now he intentionally puts himself up in
like higher states and change your state
all that stuff right but
to be able to be
more flexible with what actually
stresses you out a great anchor point
for that is to be aware of the way that
you breathe this is talking to people
that um you know that like friends that
are extreme sport athlete people base
jumpers and wing suiters and stuff like
that um
the
the thing that is consistent among those
people my friend called sketchy andy
lewis is an interesting person to look
up for this something that he's told me
is the thing that brings him back to
being like okay everything's okay my
shoot didn't my shoe didn't go you know
i gotta go to my spare wow you know or
i'm jumping off this cliff i mean he's
he's like ridiculous if you look him up
it's very interesting uh the the one
anchor point that we have to control our
state control our physio physiology
control our thoughts control our
feelings is to come back and anchor back
on the breath
everything is telling me
okay now it's chaos and we're screwed
yes the one thing that you can come back
to is you can say okay like
okay collect
what's going on what can i do yes the
breath was the anchor right so if you're
having a conversation with someone
you're getting kind of angry and you're
feeling yourself kind of like you know
your hairs are going up on edge you're
like
i don't like this feeling
breathe yes but don't over breathe
because that's going to turn you into
more of that sympathetic state breathe
less
through your nose emphasize the
exhalation
yeah i love it breathe less and fully
you know it's interesting when you're
talking about the breathing in the book
i thought it was like kind of the
opposite of wim hof but like as it was
unfolding i realized like i'm like oh
wow like that wim hof method
it's it's doing something specific for
your body that could be useful at a
certain point
but um but yeah just doing the wem hof
method with not having a reason to do it
may not be as advantageous as just
calmly breathing what's good if you if
you want to psych yourself up this it's
good if you want like cognitive clarity
yeah if you want to put you into a more
neuroplastic like adaptable like okay
like we gotta you're gonna make
decisions quick right yeah all of that
yeah yeah yeah i don't know who wim hof
is we did a video with him on our
youtube channel we'll put a link to that
in the show note sean just so because
there's this whole breathing technique
the wim hof breathing we could say the
name of that segment but we'd have to uh
put the little explicit warning
marker on this podcast
[Music]
um well i got some of the pithy from
aaron here that so i wanted to just wrap
up this uh question from satya oh yeah
he said your body is not the problem
what you're doing with your body is the
problem
and
and so
when i think about you know even the so
the sitting isn't the problem
the lack of ergonomics is not the
problem it's all about what we're doing
and for how long we're doing it and
ultimately where are we trying to go
with this yes right yeah did i say that
you did that's nice
i do that sometimes
on twitter
[Laughter]
here's my little minimal maximum for you
a sedentary body produces a restless
mind
i think quite often
when i am too sedentary for too long
too long for me personally i get to this
point where i do start to get
neurotic or ocd and and any time i want
to get out of that state of hyper
anxiety there's a hill right on my house
i just walk up that really steep hill
and i'm by the end of that i'm out of
breath a little bit and i got my heart
going
and my mind isn't going as fast as a
result yeah we've been so our our body
is still adapted to have some type of
physical threat
you know some stressor
and our reaction to that or the
opportunity is to move ourselves into
safety
away from the threat either into the
threat to resolve the threat or away
from the threat to get the heck away
from the threat right
now
fast forward to you know since cell
phones and technology you know and and
kind of you know maybe 10 000 years at
like the longest like a grand age
beginning of farming and things sure you
know but especially now
where your threats are emails and
messages and all that stuff on your
screen yeah we've manufactured threats
you still and they're legitimate threats
sure you know being outcasted from your
tribe is a legitimate threat yeah you
know losing access to your bank account
legitimate threat yeah
you know like there's there's a lot of
to be like present with what's happening
in canada you know so so
like those are real things it's not just
like oh threat it's like no that's it's
the same stuff
you know just at one point it was more
coming from the lens of oh i'm moving
through nature yeah now those threats
physiologically speaking all the same
systems are happening
the part that's been removed is the
moving ourselves to safety
so when you get some message from
someone that's wigging you out for some
reason or
rents past due or you know something
you get
upregulated with all of the hormones
that cause you to neurochemistry that
cause you to be
ready to go
your blood may be shunted out of your
vital organs into your muscles to
literally get you prepped to run or
fight
yeah so now
there's this opening
yeah right you're like wow i can like
cool like my body is stressed
yeah all right
like what do i do with that yeah
you could get a punching bag you could
go for a run like use it yes
like this is this is your juice heck
yeah use that fuel as opposed to it just
uh
putting you in that state where the mind
is becoming so restless and it amps up
the anxiety amps up the fear it amps up
the stress yeah and humans
we
run on
problems
right so if you have outsourced all of
your issues
like you're you're you're a
problem-solving system
and so if all the problems have been
outsourced to technology and you know
like others everything's just
everything's taken care of yeah you sit
there and you start to create chaos yes
you're looking for the problem
i would love
yeah to like take down a woolly mammoth
right now
you know is there some threat to my
family wow it's like nope we got
security systems we've got like the
police are at the ready like you just
sit there and just you know be a
domesticated safe human being
that's crazy you're like okay
well
we light something on fire like what can
we do yeah
well this this kind of um
this conversation's a good segue to my
my pithy answer here which is movement
is medicine and it's interesting because
they're asking you know uh
basically what can i buy
to better uh to have better health to
have better posture whatever it is while
they're sitting at their desk but really
you don't have to do anything when you
when you're feeling anxious you move you
get up and you start moving and that
alone um is a is a great piece of
medicine yeah and that's like even like
like emdr you might pay a therapist to
go and have you do this you know
horizontal eye scanning thing as you're
going through and unwinding past traumas
and such
the way that that concept
got developed was you know walking
through the woods
like when you are walking navigating
walking yourself to safety you're making
the choice to resolve whatever the
threat is yeah by engaging with these
movement patterns you're looking left
and you're looking right you're looking
left you're walking and you're looking
up and you're taking in the panorama all
that's tied in to your physiology your
own autonomic state saying okay like i
don't know exactly what's happening but
it seems like he's making decisions yeah
right he doesn't seem like he's just
like bound up
in a panic frozen state which is another
side of the autonomic nervous system
there's fight flight and then freeze
shut down
you know and that's even like there's
there's been research with this with
dogs um and probably other other animals
as well but a concept called learned
helplessness so learn helplessness is if
you put it's kind of terrible but
there's researchers put dogs on like
this like shock floor
and so they press a button shock and the
floor would be electricity going through
like oh like
this sucks yeah and then they give them
the option to to press a button and then
stop you know so they can actually make
a choice to stop the electricity
if those dogs are on that floor
with no access to a solution on how to
change for long enough
they'll go into this kind of hunched
over like the gorilla bon-bon that's sad
and depressed in the corner like what's
wrong
they'll go into this kind of shriveled
up just like helpless
state and then when you present them the
opportunity to relieve their pain they
don't choose to take it wow
man wow and that's where we are right
now yeah not everybody no no not
everybody but we have i mean we are in a
sedentary society that is full of pain
and suffering like actual physical pain
right
and
we
might be in that frozen predicament now
because all of this seems so
overwhelming and that's what i like when
with your book the align method and what
you talk about here is it doesn't have
to be overwhelming it's not about doing
the 45 minutes of this and buying the
right products or services
it's simply about moving and there's
some ways we can do that to
to help us more than if uh we were just
to try to do it on our own but for the
most part you're talking about tapping
into your basic human and and
reevaluating what it means to move in
the first place because movement like
we've got we went over some of the
seated positions like you're already at
the laptop yes like you're already there
you know it's just saying like would it
be that
heinous and terrible
to just adjust your hips an inch and a
half differently
to suddenly set up your spine to be
practicing a position of stability and
support and functionality
so that suddenly you're that central
column your axial skeleton that spinal
cord it feels spacious
enough
like again coming back into your home
it has the ability to go left right it
has full functional range of motion all
of those
all of the joints the vertebra
they're stable stacked they're not
impinged and stuck against you know one
one position they can only go one one
range of motion because it's so blown
out to the left or to the right suddenly
your central nervous system says okay i
trust you to be able to access power
so when you're in that hunched over
position it's not bad but if you try to
lift weight from that position your body
rightfully so would shut down your
access to strength
if you're practicing that position where
your body will shut down access to
strength with regularity you're
practicing
you know
weakness disease dysfunction
so there's a there's an opportunity to
just say okay like what if i just change
my shape a little bit here
and just
be aware that my body is always under a
state of construction
right now as we're having this
conversation
literally our cells are regenerating
we're circulating fluids you know we
have this it's called piezoelectric
electricity that every time you make
contact with something or lift a weight
you're creating this electrical charge
in and around those places where it kind
of it felt that pressure that pressure
sends the indication to your cells
fibroblasts fibroclass osteoblast
these these cells that either build
tissue up or break tissue down
based off of the information that it
gets from how you use your body
so when you're sitting standing you know
any position
your body is literally structuring
itself to fit the motions that you
choose throughout the day it's building
itself into that position yeah so if you
were a house
and you had some contractors come
they didn't know how to build a house
you got like the you know some like
cheap walmart contractor situation
you're like oh to save some money yeah
you know and they're not putting the
boards in right
you come into that house
there is a storm the house gets knocked
over it becomes dramatically more
expensive
that's the way you exist in your body in
daily life yeah if you don't understand
the basic mechanics of how to build a
house
and you just try to throw a house
together
it's going to be rough you need to
invest some time and energy and maybe
money to find a professional or find a
book or you know have some introspection
or find a coach to say like how do i
drive this thing
i've never really been educated on like
how i drive the most important piece of
machinery i will ever own in my entire
life
it's very simple yes yeah yes but simple
isn't necessarily easy
and that's why we we're often defaulting
to something that is far more complex in
fact
the way that we are interacting with the
world today is far more complex than the
hadza or other people but we can
simplify it and ultimately that's what
you're talking about is simplifying your
daily movements in a way that is more
natural yeah and there's more and
there's basic overarching principles
that are going to be consistent in most
any type of like weightlifting scenario
or yoga or
dance
you know and and if you sort out those
basic fundamental principles one of it
would be like understanding how to find
length and neutrality in the spine
another would be you know maybe
understanding how to breathe in a way to
either create strength to calm down to
upregulate
finding orientation of your feet
to the ground finding is there tension
in my body someplace it's not serving me
there's a guy called we mentioned before
moshe feldenkrais he called this
parasitic tension
so parasitic tension is the tension that
you might have in your shoulder your
neck or your spine or your hip or your
pelvic floor
that throughout the day it's just always
there
it's just
it just does it's just now it's just you
or who you think you are
right as i am tension who would i be
without tension
right and so
simple basic practice is to just go in
and you can maybe even just shake out
your leg a little bit
shake out your foot a little bit maybe
shake your hips a little bit maybe
rotate your spine or just
like whatever just shake it out yes and
what you'll find is for some people it
might be very challenging to just shake
it out you're shaking it i was like
am i shaking it out it's like no dude
you're not shaking it out
but also you're not talking about
something that's so grandiose either
shaking it out shake it out
i mean i think that's a great place to
wrap this up here
alabama you got anything else for us
here are some voicemail comments and
insights from our listeners
hi this is katie from glenn ellen
illinois emily was asking for advice on
how not to get seduced by new shiny
things and then feeling guilty about
buying them i also have a problem with
getting really excited about new shiny
things
and what has really helped me reduce
those impulse purchases is when i see
something new and shiny my immediate
reaction is yes i want to buy this
instead of throwing it in the basket or
shopping cart i will physically carry it
in my hands while i continue to walk
around the store and shop
this does two things number one it helps
me understand the physical bulk this
thing will take up in my life if i buy
it
it makes the idea of the true cost of
living with this item much more tangible
and number two by the time i'm done
walking around store the initial high of
wanting and then holding this new shiny
thing
had worn off carrying the item around in
the store essentially tricks my impulse
motivated brain into thinking that i
have purchased this item
and the impulse has been satisfied
without having to actually buy it
i have appreciated the object as much as
was possible and then i moved on
remember
uh
you can appreciate something without
having to buy it or own it
my name is tristan wright i'm calling
from melbourne florida ryan's comment
about wanting to talk about the
environment without being negative
resonated with me
i have increasing concerns myself and
i'm changing and adapting and part of me
keeps this to myself so i don't come
across as the software i just do better
on one hand
and then on the other hand i don't like
to bring it up because i don't want to
be criticized when my efforts are less
than perfect
one of the easiest and best things that
my husband
and i have done to effect change in our
children
is to take them to the dump i know that
that's really funny
but when they see and smell and
experience the trash
it makes such a huge impact on them
the questions to follow have been
really good and it creates an ongoing
conversation that leads to
a lot of
different rabbit trails but
the virtues of just eating an apple
rather than having applesauce packets
and it leads
the conversation also into appreciating
the mangoes that the neighbor gave you
because they didn't even have to come in
a truck from across
the united states
so we've been able to create these
conversations and it's been
a really good thing for our family
to help align with our
simple lifestyle
it's the perfect opportunity to explain
why we choose the best things that our
money can buy the fewest amount uh that
we can or the smallest amount that we
can
and why we keep those things and we
don't just constantly change and dispose
of
of of things that have value and i'm
talking about things like couches and
mattresses we try and be intentional
with our purchases it's hard to think of
things being easily disposed of when you
witness the stacks of mattresses and
couches and the birds pecking at them
and you see that firsthand and
it makes such a huge impact um on me as
an adult that
specifically
the kids
all right y'all big thanks to our guest
today aaron alexander thank you his new
book is called the align method they
just released it with 20 new
exercises also he has a podcast called
the align podcast we'll put a link to
both of those in the show notes ryan for
our added value this week
we're gonna get i'm gonna get you hip to
some uh some new music i've been
teaching our resident zillennial over
here danny unknown
um about all the tunes
we got a babyface ray which is funny
because you type in baby face until like
spotify you get the original baby face
you know the r b baby face this is not a
song from babyface although i really
enjoyed his music in the 90s there's a
new artist his name is babyface ray he's
got an album out it's called face and
this song is called dancing with the
devil
it's a song to get you moving since
we've been talking about movement today
enjoy the song or if you're listening to
this on or watching this on youtube you
can click up here is that right jordan
somewhere up here to my left your right
ryan's
right forward yeah
north
exactly
check out the song it's uh it's called
dancing with the devil from babyface ray
by the way ryan we got a bunch more
surprise questions this week like what
strength exercises do you recommend to
keep aging body strong what are the
benefits of frequent short walks versus
ones that are fewer with longer
intervals which of the five postural
archetypes are you plus a million more
questions for aaron and the minimalists
and if you want to hear all that check
out the minimalist private podcast this
week visit patreon.com
the minimalist to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our weekly private
podcast plays in your favorite podcast
app you'll also gain immediate access to
hundreds of hours of private archives
recordings of live events exclusive home
tours and our private community of
thousands of open-minded minimizers like
you
you can follow the minimalists on
tick-tock instagram facebook and twitter
at the minimalist if you want our
podcast show notes in your inbox sign up
for our email list over at
theminimalists.com
on behalf of ryan nicodemus podcast sean
alabama jordan no more social jess danny
unknown emma the immigrant and the rest
of our team i'm joshua fields milburn
reminding you to love people and use
things
because the opposite
never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine
without it